on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
appears morgan uncensored in kiev
ukraine and tonight a world exclusive
interview with two of the most iconic
people in the world right now president
vladimir zelinsky and his wife the first
lady of ukraine elena zalenska mr
brothers
thank you so much
your english is better than my ukrainian
yes that's right that's for sure
it was a wide-ranging long
fascinating
heart-rending occasionally laugh out
loud against all the odds interviewed my
grandmother she remembers churchill he
rallied the whole country yeah i think
you're doing the same as churchill i'm
trying
we're two compelling people
and at the end of it one thing's for
sure ukraine right now could not be in
better hands than they are with their
president and their first lady
[Music]
i'm pierce morgan uncensored in kiev
ukraine tonight a world exclusive
interview with the president of ukraine
vladimir zelinski and his wife the first
lady elena zolenska
mr president first lady thank you both
very much indeed for taking this time to
sit down with me i greatly appreciate it
and firstly thank you for giving me the
honor of moderating your summit first
ladies and gentlemen it was an amazing
day and we'll come to that i want to ask
you first with the five months into the
wall into the sixth month now
how are you both doing how are you
coping with this
how are you doing how are you doing
[Music]
well if i may say so to be honest i have
this feeling as if it were one day that
is why when it was the sixth day the
seventh day of war since that day i
really have this feeling that all of
this is one very long day
i don't really see the difference
between five months or six months the
only difference is when we feel that at
the battlefield the situation is
stabilized
or we know that at some points in some
positions we are advancing
and i keep thinking about that
but another point is my family my wife
they have found the format how sometimes
we can have this possibility of seeing
each other
thank you for the interview
this interview is one of the good
opportunities for us to see each other
that is very important for us
as you know we are all human beings and
we have to be strong
sometimes we want to have someone close
to be next to us and that is what you
miss in these moments
yes i miss my children i miss my wife
it is impossible to get used to it
everything else you can get used to
is this like a tv date
yes thank you for this tv date
yes yes because each day each time when
we have this interview we experience joy
because we have the chance to see each
other throughout past days past months
because during this period velodimer has
been living at his workplace and i'm
with children but we are in another
place we were separated and i can see
him only several times per week in the
office but children do not get to see
him very often of course they they miss
it under such a serious period in their
life of our daughter who graduated from
school she's entering university and
today she's going to take an exam and
she's preparing thoroughly for this even
she really needs her dad to be around to
be able to talk to him and this period
of time and she's entering this adult
life so
it's important to make sure that there's
such a smooth transition for her but
unfortunately there's something we
cannot afford and
what is supportive what helps us
you understand that you are not alone
all of the ukrainian people are in this
situation too many are separated and all
of us are waiting for our victory
and waiting for normal life to be
reunited again and just to lead normal
lives like ordinary people live
the only thing that i could add here is
that i absolutely agree with olenna i
think that for those people who are in
occupied territories it's much more
difficult and this is something one
cannot get used to actually
so
we have to try our best to make sure we
can de-occupy these territories and at
least to save the lives of these people
and to make sure that there is still
hope for them
these kind of situations that can make
or break your marriage
is your marriage stronger do you think
because of what you've gone through in
the last few months what do you think i
should i have i have to begin to answer
okay
okay i love ready
i agree with the theory that marriage
gets stronger with challenges and i
think in our case it would be the same
we have become more interested in each
other
i think in our case it will be the same
story
we have got something else to say to
each other
that is why i want this challenge to
make us more united no distribution what
do you think about it
my answer wouldn't be different
you should have your own opinion about
it
of course i i have my own opinions and
when you're next to me your opinion has
priority but i'm interested to hear what
you have to say
yeah well what i can say is that i
didn't have any other experience
actually
because i have only one wife and i'm
happy
yes that's the right answer it is yes
you see
i am happy to have this set up i am
happy that in my life i have got one
wife one love and one family
[Music]
i never got any feeling that there was
anything wrong with us or in our
relationship yeah
[Music]
or maybe do you feel unhappy with me
sometimes
not with you but without you i'm very
unhappy yes yes right you are
[Music]
that is why i can't notice any big
changes the war is making our
relationship stronger
what is so nice i think is you your
relationship was founded on humor comedy
uh you you wrote comedy scripts you were
writing and performing
and i was going to ask you later in the
interview if you had any chance to even
laugh together and then here you are
laughing together and it's very nice to
see that because that's how you met and
fell in love was making each other laugh
it's true there are no moments of
laughing
in our these days world death is true
and and i and sometimes we i i can see
smile and and also i i have this
minutes for smiling i think it helps
helps very much is it true i've got a
question for you mr president
is it true that you you met at high
school you were high school sweethearts
is it true you got together with two
friends male friends
and all of you propose marriage
to your wife and to two other women at
the same time it is true it was yes
i don't remember exactly why we we did
such ways if you remember could you
please tell a story yes
they had very many very many
performances then
and we were always on the road sometimes
it was with them and their girlfriends
were also with them and when we saw that
we had more flexible schedule for the
upcoming months
then the guys decided to put it to good
use because we planned to get married
anyway
i remember you three guys saying let's
do it and everything will be okay and we
agreed
let's let's do the right thing and we
agreed somehow you know
we agreed yes
i remember we were having a wedding
ceremony every week yes yeah so you know
it was every week that we got married it
was the 31st of august
hours is on the 6th of september and
then another couple on the 13th of
september so each saturday we would have
another function to celebrate it yes
that shows that at the time i didn't
have many friends but if i had 10 or 20
friends we would have had weddings all
over the years oh no
it's a lovely story and you all got
married within the same two-week period
right
yes all three marriages amazing
mr president
well the most important thing is not to
have divorces every week that we are
managing
we are managing
yes we are managing is not the right
word
we are in love with each other okay
okay okay mr president when this war
started that awful night back in
february
you appeared very soon afterwards and
made a video
address which you put on social media i
remember watching it in real time and
being very moved by it
and it was really your decision to stay
here in ukraine and to encourage the
people of ukraine to fight for their
country
some leaders might have left what made
you stay
yep
or
well it couldn't have gone any other way
because the president is a leader of its
people
the people voted for me and the
strengths of our state
this is something that i have already
mentioned the strengths of our state
this is consolidation
this is unity of our people
all of us together
the government the people the servicemen
people just wanted started they would go
to the streets they would stop tanks
other military vehicles so the
government had to stay in the center of
the decision making processes
it was very important to make sure that
there is no informational chaos because
we cannot say that this intimidation
works because
otherwise they would say that their
informational propaganda actually won
that the government would leave this is
what they wanted
this chaos because chaos is the weakness
of the state
this is the weakness of institutions
so one can occupy some territory very
quickly
frankly yes
unfortunately in some places some
settlements or towns of ukraine this is
what happened
with some police officers some local
authorities yes they would
they would actually run away and it was
possible for the troops to address
sooner but actually there was a lot of
resistance and it was next to impossible
to occupy because of the resistance
coming from people
this is why we really tried really hard
to make sure that other territories
remain integral that it was the only way
for me to act
and i understood the consequences
and i think that these consequences they
were so much more important than what
happens to me the next day
first lady that night you had to wake
your children and tell them this war had
started your children at 18 and 9 years
old
that must have been a very difficult
thing to do and then you had to leave
your husband as he went to lead the
country and you had to leave him perhaps
fearing i don't know you tell me that
you may never see him again
yes it was difficult it i was a little
bit worried actually when i had to wake
up the children to let them know that
the war had begun
and that we had to pack some stuff but
luckily i didn't have to do that because
when i entered the room of my daughter
she was already awake and she understood
everything because you know social media
everything works so fast these days
i didn't see in her eyes any panic
she just asked me
what do we have to do now
and that was
exactly the same question which i
addressed to my husband
and what he told me was wait wait and i
will tell you
how to discuss
them i had some thoughts
would it be possible for me to see him
again how long is going to last what
happens next if he was there but i try
not to show it to the children that i
was confused that i was scared and
i was not
really scared
but it was important for me to be
in a cheerful mood to to keep talking to
them to smile to them
that is what i had to do and
after this very long day believe me my
cheeks hurt because i had to smile so
much and to be cheerful
and there's voludimir just said as for
any ukrainian the 24th of february keeps
repeating every day
you know this is the 24th of february is
a permanent condition in which we are
living right now
as the circumstances are changing but
we're just waiting for one thing
when
all of that is going to be
all rolled back and we will be back to
our normal lives that is why i don't i
wouldn't really want anyone in the whole
world to enjoy these horrific days that
we had to go through at the end of
february yes but we hope for better
absolutely we are sure about our future
we believe in peace we believe in our
victory
and i absolutely agree
this is the way it is we are living in
these times social media they work
faster they explain things faster than
parents do sometimes and we can say that
it's not only about our children
we have children of war they hear a lot
about what's happening
they understand that this war made them
more grown up and there are very many
important things which have to be
explained by parents
i am proud of that
i am proud of our army
and as a father i would be proud if my
son became a soldier i can provide
support for him
i know he is wearing military style
clothing
he's got quite a lot of weapons not the
kind of weapons we've got from our
partners
he's ready to protect his mother and our
family
it must be strange for your children
because you've become this this
international hero to many people
uh incredibly famous the whole world
knows of you and is inspired by you and
yet to your children you're just your
dad
and you they see you on television i
presume and it's still it's their father
you're not this global female by still
father
yeah i understand
them but have you seen them at all
yes at some point
there was the movement of my family to
different places it was important in
terms of security of my family
it was not possible for us to
communicate or to use any means of
communication for some longer periods of
time
at some point it was possible for us to
have an online date and i saw my
children
i did them all how how is that
nice great
i'm proud of them and they are proud of
me and it is such a delight because this
is what it gets you through this is what
i can hear first lady
the world sees your husband as a hero
is he your hero
yeah maybe you want to answer without me
then
yes i think it would be better
i think that i have already answered
similar questions a couple of times
already and if each time i have to
answer this question because of
victory is getting closer and closer you
know i cannot make up any other answer
there's only one truth i have always
known that he's the most trustworthy
person ever
and under this condition this is
something the world learned
and the same is true about our children
he has always been a champion for them
the best dad the best person in our
family
and right now
they're not really surprised they take
it as a test they have this confidence
and they support
i'm one of the best ones in our family
yes you're the one of the many best
people in our family but there's not
many as we don't really have a big
family mr president having having spent
time with
having spent time with the first lady at
the summit all day are you familiar with
the phrase punching above your weight
are you familiar with that
it phrase you're doing you're very lucky
you're doing very well yeah yeah yeah i
think so
you agree
with us yes
i'm very lucky with my wife
i got really lucky to have her as a wife
with my family with my children
i think that i'm a happy person i am
absolutely a happy person
what is your
view of vladimir putin the man who is
leading this war
he is enemy number one in this war
it seems to me the scariest thing about
it is that he is in fact sane and he
understands what he's doing it is
difficult to put it into words
it's not possible to understand how one
crooked idea can throw the whole of
mankind into the medieval ages
i really don't have words
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you've said on a more serious note that
the russians
you're the number one target for them
and your family is the number two target
that must be
a constant pressure for all of you
not really about you thinking about your
family yes in this case the family is at
the center of attention and yes this is
true
these targets still remain for some
people from the russian federation
as far as i am concerned
i think it is a given i think
that it is a part of this situation we
are in
and we are in a state of war
i think that
any person can become a target
there is an example there is a good
example of the number of
artillery missiles and some other
strikes which took place
innocent people suffer
civilians suffer our soldiers and me
if i can really put it this way
we are at war
we were at war yes we understand that
these things could happen
the result could be a bad one some
people lose their lives
what about suffering of civilians
their families
common people
and
the only thing they did was being a
ukrainian
because this is what it is for ukrainian
soldiers and politicians
that is why i think this is something
which is unsettling
and first lady
for you as a mother
to
know that the russians
are targeting not just your husband as
president but you and your potentially
your children your family
for any mother that that must be a
terrifying thought
[Music]
i tried never to think about this
numbers of targets because when you
think in terms of target number one
target number two
if you think too much into it then you
can become really paranoid and yes i
understand i'm a mother like many other
mothers in ukraine that is why all
ukrainians are targets
number two and of course
it's all unpleasant feeling
i don't want to think that they
want to do this to our family i'm trying
to push this kind of thoughts away i can
see that
you can see what they did to civilians
and what they're doing now in any part
of our country i don't understand what
they've got in mind and possibly we are
in danger i don't want to allow this
kind of thought to go deep into my mind
because i could feel scared
and this is not what we need right now
first lady i remember your husband going
to bucha and the emotion
and fury on his face
i know you felt the same
about this and you've talked about
how the civilization and then there's
what's going on here
and the russians are behaving in a way
that you just never imagined
possible a total lack of humanity
tell me about that
any civilized person during this war
would have terrible feelings
fear and hate towards the enemy and we
tried to explain it to come on english
men
when they take their child to bed try to
imagine what is going to happen at night
if they heard the sirens
and explosions next to where they live
what would they grab from their
children's bedroom and where would they
run to if they recognized as already a
large queue of cars trying to leave the
city are they going to take their pets
with them and imagine if you stayed
there and you under occupation
imagine the road you usually take your
child to school with tanks on it
the grave of your clothes relative in
your bag garden because you can't have a
normal funeral to remember them
and imagine
you have to search for water and your
only source is a dirty puddle like it
wasn't marie opal
the medical service is not available
just imagine you are in your home and in
two hours time you are forced to deal
with these kinds of problems just to
survive you don't understand why this is
happening
what is your
view of vladimir putin the man who is
leading this war
it is difficult to put it into words
it's not possible to understand how one
crooked idea
can throw the whole of mankind into the
medieval ages
i really don't have words
and i really don't want to say anything
aloud
because normal words don't exist to
describe this
mr president he is your
enemy in this war he's the leader of
russia they've been doing despicable
things to your people bombing maternity
hospitals
committing war crimes no question
torturing people murdering them
what is your view
your opinion of vladimir putin
ah
well it's clear and as you have
mentioned he is enemy number one in this
war
it seems to me the scariest thing about
it is that he is in fact sane and he
understands what he's doing
i'd say that's the scariest conclusion i
can make that he understands what he's
doing
he knows how many people he kills
he knows how many people were raped and
by who
and the number of children killed or
deported
therefore
i only understand one thing
the world allowed the situation to
develop
it allowed such a person to emerge
with that ideology and attitude towards
people
the world should understand that this
result this mistake to allow this
situation is the responsibility of the
whole world to give the possibility for
this to happen it is not about democracy
i wouldn't want to mix these things
because some leaders say that what did
we have to do it it is not really about
democracy do you believe do you believe
you can win this war
yes
no question
i don't only believe it i know it will
happen
we will win
we already showed the whole world that
he can kill us
but to conquer our people is impossible
millions of soldiers have died but he
cannot occupy the people
he can occupy these towns and villages
but all of them would be destroyed
because without ruining them they will
not be able to take those places
how important has it been to get support
from
so much of the world
for ukraine
this is the daichi this is the goal
number two like you said there is the
aim number one number two
but there are also the goals of ukraine
our goals is our land
that's number one
both number one and number two this is
our land and our people
how we can get it we need some help
and nowadays it's very important
but
number two is of course the union of our
country
these trends of the country and it leads
to the help from like an ambulance
they help from the world nine one one
from the whole world
and exactly right now we need this
powerful help do you believe he would
ever use a nuclear weapon putin yeah i
don't know
i don't know
i don't know what his aims are i don't
know what the civilized world allows him
to do because if it shows its weakness
he will use everything
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
this is talk tv
[Music]
the other argument that you will hear
and i'm sure you've heard it is that
putin has all these nuclear weapons no
one should do anything to trigger world
war three
i think that if he decides to use it
then
there will be no reason for that
explicit reason is only about his
decision
their ambitious plans just listen to me
in any other case what if tomorrow he
says you know what germany i think that
half of there was this division in the
country after the second world war and i
think that that part of germany belongs
to us
i think that we should have some
influence upon the territory and our
troops should be there
any other case
i decided to have nuclear weapons
raise our hands
and do this
i don't
do you believe he would ever use a
nuclear weapon putin yeah i don't know
i don't know
i don't know what his aims are i don't
know what the civilized world allows him
to do because if it shows its weakness
he will use everything
you mentioned germany mr president one
of the more sickening things that putin
has said is that he's liberating
ukrainian people from nazis by
implication you you're a jewish man you
had relatives who were murdered by the
nazis
that must have been for you are
particularly
egregious insult
it's not that it is unpleasant to hear
it you know
this is i don't pay attention to that
these are empty words
if something is very populous for their
people
i pay no attention to this
if you want to draw attention to these
questions
then the first you need to think about
their first actions and the results of
what they're
doing they are nazis and take a look at
biography and the people who are close
to putin
his family what happened to them
during the times when the nazis were out
there during the second world war what
was happening
who did he get to lose and for him to
take a look at my family
what is their blood
where are they now
and why i don't truly have a big family
i mean
people who are still here by the way
tortured by nazis
what happened to his family
were they under occupation
they were not
so what was happening
so i would probably pay attention to
that
it's not really about him i think that
political leaders of the russian
federation
i would pay more attention to their
families is of the utmost importance
president biden
said that putin should be removed from
office
do you agree
with that
i think that
any war ends with when you talk about
diplomatic solutions
and
the impression that i have
is that
the result of this diplomacy
is the conversation between the
ukrainian part
with the presence of our partners
and the russian federation
i think that this is the only model
to talk with with someone else
not the contemporary leader of the
russian federation is there more america
could be doing right now they're so
powerful obviously as a country
yeah
as the president of a country that is in
a war
i can tell you that the help would not
be sufficient until the war is over
and
a few times i've spoken with president
biden
and
i told him about our people and about
our country i said
forgive me if i'm quite firm in my
position maybe some things are not very
diplomatic
but he gave me quite a dignified
response that he understands and he
would do the same in my place of course
he would do the same thing there are
people in america
some on the republican side in
particular who think that america
shouldn't be spending all this money on
a war here which has nothing to do with
them
they think there are more important
things in america like inflation and so
on that they should be working on what
is your message to those americans who
do not think america should be as
heavily involved
we are fighting for absolutely communal
values that are universally understood
some time ago i responded that war
doesn't have a distance
and the war in ukraine is still the war
against those values that are professed
in the united states and in europe
the distance doesn't exist today
today
russian rockets can fly over a few
thousand kilometers and tomorrow they
will have rockets that can cover tens of
thousands of kilometers what difference
does it make
they kill civilians who do not agree
with the politics of the president of
russia
so this war
here and now in ukraine
and forgive me that i'm saying it so
cynically
it's for the safety of europe
as long as we are resisting
the integrity of the united states will
continue
therefore we are giving our lives for
your values and the joint security of
the world
therefore inflation is nothing
is nothing
ask those people who lost their children
their peace their property at the
beginning of the full-scale russian
invasion who is thinking about masks and
coding who is thinking about inflation
these things are secondary the most
important thing is to survive and
preserve your life family and your
country therefore at the moment we are
doing this job but the west has to help
us
first lady is it true that he didn't
tell you that he was going to run for
president
well
he forgot
you forgot
you forgot to tell your wife you're
running for president yes but i said
wait a minute
you found that on tv
[Laughter]
i was not laughing so much so loud
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i want to take you back to a few years
ago when you were a comedy performer in
a hugely popular
tv show in which you played an
anti-establishment figure
who runs for president and becomes
president
and then you actually run for president
in real life
and you become president
it's a bit crazy when you
say it like that
the question is that for many people it
was surreal
that you were playing a role in a comedy
show as someone who becomes president
and then you become the real president
well it is a reality this is the reality
which we're all living now to be honest
i am proud of the fact that this is how
it happens
i'm proud of being the president of
ukraine
that's people voted for me
it is a reality and about this surreal
thing i think it's more about what is
actually happening with our neighbors
for very many years we
they lived alongside
and then they decided to attack us and
to kill us
i think it is way more surreal than this
first lady is it true that he didn't
tell you that he was going to run for
president
say through say true
well
he forgot
you forgot you forgot to tell your wife
you're running for president
he understood that probably i wouldn't
have been fond of this idea and that it
would take a couple of hours of very
difficult negotiations with me that is
why probably each day he was thinking
that this is the day that this is the
moment i should tell her you know but he
kept postponing it then it was on tv i
saw his new year's address it was new
year's night and found out he was
actually running
wait a minute
you found that on tv
really
mr president
really you announced it on television
[Laughter]
[Music]
there was a long you know some 10
minutes but that wasn't it okay say
everything okay this question was up in
the air there were some discussions but
he didn't really want to do to keep
asking him you are going to tell them is
it happening is it not somehow i believe
that at that point he will tell me but i
didn't really think that that would be
the moment
you have to explain yourself yes i mean
i've heard of not telling your wife
things but not telling you you're going
to be president it's like crazy
what were you thinking
[Music]
no
no
you see was a difficult decision for our
family
[Music]
it's true that we didn't talk about it
for a long period of time
but
we had been talking about it and
then i had been talking about it
separately that's true
we've been putting off talking about it
and avoiding it for a long time
because my family was not prepared to
let me go
you are right my first public statement
that was before the day of new year
i mentioned that
i am intending to run for the office
it is true
that was the moment when
i heard about that
okay
[Laughter]
that is my that's you know come on
why not
later do it later when you apologize
again
you were written off at the start of
this war by the new york times called
you an inept leader unsuitable for war
another headline this comedian turned
president is in seriously over his head
they couldn't have been more wrong
you've turned out to be the right man at
the right time for your country you've
been an incredibly inspiring leader in
this war
what do you say to those who doubted you
what can i say i'm happy that right now
they can see how wrong they were and
that they admitted first lady do you
feel that ukraine is fortunate to have
your husband
leading the country at this time
well i think on behalf of the rest of
the country i cannot really say but this
is how i feel it and yes this is what i
can say on behalf of everyone that we
believe in him and this is the way
people feel i'm not only his wife i also
a citizen of this country and i like
this president
at the summit which was magnificent your
first lady in first gentleman summit
which i was proud to help moderate for
you um there was a moment when i
revealed that my football team arsenal
have signed a ukrainian player
alexander zinchenko and i'm very excited
about this it's just happened and i
asked the audience are there any arsenal
fans in the room and you put your hand
up you're an [ __ ]
yes i think that zitchenko is the person
who is loved by everyone in ukraine he
is one of the most recent heroes of the
nation and ukrainians they always
fervently support football players and
zinchenko is such a nice guy and even
girls like him so much this is why i'm
hopeful when zinchenko starts playing
our people will become fans of this
football team
mr president are you are you an arsenal
supporter yeah maybe there's some other
footballers that you like
let me explain
i know some of them personally let me
explain why you should be because
arsenal
is named after a weapons factory which
used to make weapons for the british
army and the royal navy
and our motto the motto of the club is
in latin
victoria
concordia crescent which stands for
victory through harmony
it's appropriate
honestly we are all fans of sinchenko as
olenna has mentioned
personally i know very many great
ukrainian football players so to be
honest they are doing a great thing
they are working really hard they're
well-known people and they're helping us
a lot
shivchenko is a great person
i cannot say that i love zinchengo over
shevchenko because and shivchenko will
stop talking to me
and then i can do the opposite thing
are so many of them believe me there are
some legendary figures
they took arms and they are on the front
line
and we know some football players from
other teams
from dinamo
so
i mean that i'm a fan of football like
any man in ukraine
we've now established thanks to the
first lady you're all arsenal supporters
and i actually have a gift for you which
i will give you after the interview of
arsenal shirts
for the president for the first lady and
for both of your children
because we need your support
as we'll give you our support um thank
you both very much indeed for all the
time that you've given me today i think
i speak on everyone's behalf from the
united kingdom
when i salute you for the courage
that you've shown the inspiration you've
shown the people here
we're all behind you
we need you to win this war we
understand the world needs you to win
this war
keep fighting
and i think the words i need to use are
slava ukraine
glory to the heroes thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years at fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that romaine had won and
at half past two four to three after
nigel farage had already said he lost it
turned out he hadn't lost and it turned
out we were leaving the european union
so that was quite shocking
[Music]
is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams
rebecca vardy's called the outcome of
the wagatha christie libel trial wrong
after she lost her case at the high
court
a judge ruled that colleen rooney's
claims her former friend leaked stories
to the sun newspaper in 2019 were
substantially true
a nine-year-old girl who was stabbed to
death in lincolnshire last night has
been named by police as lilia valueteer
the lithuanian national was found dead
in boston two people have been arrested
in connection
amrishi sunak has again tried to
distance himself from the current
government's record as he set out his
vision for the country if he wins the
leadership contest just weeks after
resigning as chancellor he told andrew
neil he would set up a task force to
tackle the growing backlog in the nhs
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you